in the absence of some defeater it seems
to me that were perfectly within our
rights in believing that there is an
objective realm of moral values and
duties just as we're within our rights
and believing that there is a world of
physical objects around us hey hey and
welcome this is the Ben Shapiro show
Sundays special and were eager to
welcome to the program philosopher and
theologian dr. William Lane Craig he's
also the author of the book on guard and
the presidents of reasonable faith we'll
get to that conversation in just a
moment but first it's spring the time of
year when seeds grow into flowers and
you grow up financially at least like
grow up do it
your family needs protection if
something happens to you that means you
need life insurance thankfully policy
genius makes it easy to get the
financial security without the growing
pains policy genius is the easy way to
buy life insurance online in just two
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find your best price once
you apply the policy genius team will
handle all the paperwork and the red
tape no Commission's no hidden fees just
financial protection and peace of mind
no strings attached and policy genius
doesn't just simplify life insurance
they also make it easy to compare and
buy home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance so next time you
stop to smell the roses pull out your
phone head over to policy genius com
policy genius spring is here kick it off
by nipping life insurance in the bud and
make sure by the way that you're being
an adult and you really want to be
buried in a pauper's grave and leave
your children banking on the streets you
don't want to do that you want to make
sure that your family is okay if god
forbid something should happen to you
prepare like an adult go to policy
genius calm again that is policy genius
calm go check them out right now they do
make life insurance easy dr. Craig
thanks so much for stopping by I really
appreciate your time
my pleasure good to be with you so why
don't we start with this there there
we're living in an increasingly secular
age where people by polling numbers
seculars are now by polling numbers the
largest religious constituency in
America why do you think we're seeing
such a decline in religious belief in
the West right now I think what's
happening is not so much increasing
secularization been as the collapse of
the old mainline Christian denominations
like the Episcopalians the Catholics the
Presbyterians the Congregationalists and
so forth
and as a result there is an increasing
polarization in American society people
are evacuating the middle and going
either to the secular end or to the
evangelical end evangelicals are
maintaining their percentage of the
American population keeping up with the
population growth but the impression of
increasing secularization exists because
the middle is emptying out and these old
line denominations are are collapsing
why do you think they are collapsing in
on themselves and we're seeing it in
Judaism as well that the old
conservative Jews and reformed Jews
they're kind of dying away and you're
getting the modern orthodox movement
even moving toward more orthodoxy why do
you think that's happening right now
that's very interesting and I think it's
a reflection of the fact that people who
are just nominally religious in a sense
come to the realization that they don't
really believe this and so why should
you get up in the dark and the cold I'm
a Sunday morning to go worship somebody
you don't really think is there and so
as a result those who have been simply
nominal in their beliefs I think are
increasingly recognizing that in fact
their secular and the unfortunate
byproduct of this is that Christianity
has lost its place of cultural influence
in the United States as this middle
mainline denominations empties out and
it's my hope that in coming decades
increasingly these evangelical
denominations which are holding fast to
biblical truth will begin to assume that
position of cultural influence that was
once held by the mainline denominations
well free didn't mean she declared the
death of God back in the late 19th
century and it took a while for that to
become a reality in the United States as
far as occupying any significant portion
of the public mind we're still
significantly more religious than Europe
but starting in the 1960s and moving
beyond there was a real move away from
religious belief generally what do you
think priests age that why do you think
that happened
considering we we have a civilization
built on judeo-christian values were
incredibly prosperous incredibly free
and yet we seem to be moving away from a
lot of the religious beliefs upon which
our society is based well I think in
Europe and in Canada it's the lingering
shadow of the Enlightenment that swept
away the church along with the monarchy
because these two were aligned and
resulted in a deep disaffection with
Christianity which was seen to be
aligned with the old order in the United
States I think it's hard to
underestimate the influence of the
Vietnam War that war tore this culture
into and resulted I think in the
alienation of many many young people
from the values and the beliefs of their
elders and I suspect we're still living
with the results of that well there's
sort of a mainstream discomfort with
with religion that we see these days
religious believers are seen as sort of
anachronistic if you say that you
believe in the Bible or the God of the
Bible then you're seen as somewhat of a
fool these days as somebody who speaks
on college campuses a lot and I speak in
purely secular forms about politics
whenever I'm asked about religion it's
always phrased in a sense of derision or
condescension why would you believe all
that old stuff well your work has been
based on the idea that faith is in fact
backed by reason the other the presence
of God is a reasonable assumption to
make about the universe why do you think
that first of all there is that gap that
occurred that breach that occurred
between reason and faith that's who were
considered to be mutual buttressing and
supportive of one another for centuries
what what presage that gap well I do
think that this is confined to certain
disciplines at the university
particularly the soft sciences and the
Social Sciences those who were
disaffected by the Vietnam War and the
Cultural Revolution went into
anthropology sociology women's studies
literature religious studies and so
forth but in the hard sciences and in my
discipline philosophy I
frankly there's a renaissance of
theistic belief and there is a virtual
revolution going on in anglo-american
philosophy right now where Christian
philosophers represent a significant and
respected voice in the philosophical
community so I find there's tremendous
interest on university campuses in these
topics when I debate a secularist on our
university campuses we will have
hundreds and sometimes thousands of
students attend these debates and the
discussions are always rational
respectful deliberative and so my
experience is that there is tremendous
interest in our culture and in the
university age group in hearing a
rational fair discussion of issues
related to religious belief but one of
the things I think that's happened in
the religious community is you see
people who are brought up in religious
homes and they're taught the stories of
the Bible they're never taught any
deeper philosophy or theology that
attaches to that so they have sort of a
children's eyes view of what God is and
and how to how to think about God you
sort of think of God still as the old
man in the sky who's controlling things
what if what in your opinion is the most
reasonable proof of God what have you
found to be the most convincing proof of
God's existence well I think those are
two questions for me my favorite
argument for the existence of God that I
find the most compelling is a version of
the cosmological argument which goes
like this
whatever begins to exist has a cause
something can't just come into being
from nothing secondly the universe began
to exist I think we have both good
philosophical arguments and scientific
evidence for the finitude of the past
from which it follows third therefore
the universe has a cause and when you do
a conceptual analysis of what it is to
be a cause of the universe you arrive at
a being which is an uncaused beginning
less timeless spaceless enormous ly
powerful personal creator of the
universe
so for me that is a very convincing
argument for God but I find that with
university students that's not the most
convincing argument you can ignore
philosophical arguments for the finitude
of the past or scientific evidence for
the beginning of the universe but the
argument that I find I think the most
compelling is what I call the moral
argument and it would go like this one
if God does not exist then objective
moral values and duties do not exist
that is to say in the absence of God
everything's becomes socio-culturally
relative to but objective moral values
and duties do exist there are some moral
absolutes some objective values and
duties 3 therefore God exists now this
is an argument which is impossible I
think to ignore because every day you
get up you answer by how you treat other
people whether you regard them as having
intrinsic moral value or whether they
are mere means to be used for your ends
and so this argument I find tends to be
the most convincing for people so for
purposes of elucidating these arguments
I'm going to play devil's advocate with
you a little bit on both of these
arguments let's start with the
cosmological argument that you're making
so the Richard Dawkins comeback the one
that you hear most frequently with
regard to the finitude of time and and
the idea that everything has a cause is
okay well then what caused God yes it's
important to state the first premise
correctly been it's not everything has a
cause it is everything that begins to
exist has a cause something cannot come
into being without a cause but if
something is eternal never began to
exist there's no need for a cause so
that objection of the argument is simply
based on a misunderstanding of the first
premise what must we posit such an
eternal being or could we just have in
infinity of regressive Oz's well that's
the second premise that the universe
began to exist
and I think there are deep philosophical
problems with the idea of an infinite
pass for example how did we get to today
if you had to go through an infinite
number of prior events one at a time I
that would be like trying to count on
all the negative numbers one at a time
ending at zero which seems an absurd
task moreover we have remarkable
scientific evidence from the Big Bang
expansion of the universe and the
thermodynamic properties of the universe
which suggest that the universe cannot
be infinite in the past but must have
had a beginning around 13.8 billion
years ago so I think that second premise
is very powerfully supported both
philosophically and scientifically okay
and then on the the other argument the
moral argument the argument that I've
heard made in in contravention of that
it's an argument made by Dawkins Harris
Brett Weinstein evolutionary biologist
you suggest that morality there is a
certain sense of morality that is innate
to mammals that you see even in species
that are not our own sense of primitive
altruism a sense of kinship protection
for example so is it possible that that
morality is embedded on a very basic
level in in behavior of mammals beyond
the idea of an objective morality that
we think about in therefore in acts that
it's just embedded in than in the
natural code this response is almost a
textbook example of the genetic fallacy
the genetic fallacy is trying to
invalidate a point of view by showing
how that point of view came to be held
even if evolution and social
conditioning has programmed into us a
certain set of moral beliefs that does
nothing to show that those beliefs are
false indeed if moral values are
gradually discovered rather than
gradually invented than our gradual and
fallible apprehension of the moral realm
no more undermines the objectivity of
that realm than our gradual fallible
apprehension of the physical world
undermines the objectivity of the
physical realm in the absence of some
defeater it seems to me that we're
perfectly within our rights in believing
that there is an objective realm of
moral values and duties just as we're
within our rights and believing that
there is a world of physical objects
around us so I want to ask you to steel
man the opposing argument so now play a
theist so you're so you're that you're
the atheist of the room and it's your
job to attack the arguments that you've
just made what do you think are the
strongest objections to the cosmological
argument and the strongest objections
you the moral argument that you've made
well I think that the first premise of
the cosmological argument is
unassailable for any sincere seeker
after truth with respect to the
philosophical arguments perhaps what the
skeptic might simply say is that
infinity is just a really strange thing
and yes it leads to counterintuitive
consequences but that's just the way
things are with respect to the
scientific evidence he can always hold
out hope that the advance of physical
theory will overturn the current
consensus in astrophysics and cosmology
and restore a past eternal universe and
that's about the best he can do I think
there isn't much prospect for that but
he could hold out hope so in a second I
want to ask you about the Bertrand
Russell theory that essentially posits
brute facts in place of God as the as
the beginnings of these sorts of
arguments but first hiring is
challenging but there is one place you
can go our hiring is simple fast and
smart it's a place where growing
businesses connect qualified candidates
that place
Zipp recruiters calm slash bend and
guest zip recruiter sends your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and then invites them to apply to your
job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes each one and
spotlights the top candidates say never
miss a great match
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash been
guest that is a zip recruit com slash
been guest be an GU est B and GU est
zipper
komm /a been guest you want to up your
hiring you wanna make your employment
based better you want to do it quickly
and easily go checkout zip recruit the
smartest way to hire zip recruiters comm
slash been guest to try it out zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire so
philosopher Bertrand Russell suggested
that God is sort of unnecessary to these
conversations that instead of trying to
look for a final cause this is just the
way things are so in other words if you
go back to the very beginning okay so
something sprang from nothing why not
this is a different cosmological
argument that Russell was responding to
this argument goes something like this
everything that exists has an
explanation of its existence either in
the necessity of its own nature or in an
external cause number two the if the
universe has an explanation of its
existence then its explanation is a
transcendent eternal cause premise 3
would be the universe exists and from
that it follows logically that therefore
the explanation of the universe is an
external transcendent cause now what
Russell denied was the first premise he
said that there doesn't need to be an
explanation either in the necessity of
the things nature or in an external
cause now I disagree with Russell on
that but notice that that sceptical
response doesn't apply to the first
version of the cosmological argument
because in that case we're talking about
something that begins to exist something
that comes into being and I don't think
even Russell would have affirmed that
something could come into being without
a cause even if for some eternally
existing universe you might say well it
just exists with no explanation so one
of the counters that sort of been
posited nowadays to to that idea is the
sort of David Hume well things pop in
and out of existence and people tend to
point to quantum mechanics as the as the
basis so how do you respond to the
quantum mechanical argument that it
appears that certain particles are
almost literally winking in and out of
existence let me first respond to human
this because I think he's been missing
understood what Hume said was that you
cannot prove the causal principle either
by demonstration or intuition but he
said in a letter to John Stewart
I never affirmed anything so absurd as
that something could come into being
without a cause I only said that it's
not proved through demonstration or
intuition now in quantum mechanics
things don't come into being out of
nothing the quantum vacuum is definitely
not what the layperson means by vacuum
namely a state of nothingness the
quantum vacuum is a sea of roiling
energy having a rich physical structure
and governed by physical laws it is most
emphatically not nothing and therefore
when people like Lawrence Krauss and
certain others say well the the modern
physics shows that something can come
from nothing this is a deliberate abuse
of science and is grossly misrepresented
of in fact what the science says so I'm
go through one more argument with you
and then I want to talk about the
importance of religion as opposed to
theology which are not quite the same
thing because you're making some some
reason based arguments for the existence
of God but these aren't obviously
arguments for Christian revelation or
Jewish revelation although I don't think
there are good reasons to be a Christian
theist for a little part of my work and
I'm gonna get to that in in just one
second but I first want to tackle the
another argument that that you hear made
a lot and that seems I think to be given
short shrift there the the ontological
argument the Anselm argument so the
ontological if you could spell that out
and then why people seem to get this so
wrong because the way they posited is
that it's the simplistic argument if we
just posit in Island then you could
somehow debunk it which would make no
sense because any person could have
discovered that one Saint Anselm said it
as opposed to spending hundreds of years
trying to figure it out so what is the
ontological argument the analogical
argument in a nutshell says that if it's
even possible that God exists then it
follows that God actually exists and
this argument has been stated and
defended with great sophistication by
philosophers like Alvin Plantinga
for example and I like you I'm persuaded
the
this is actually a sound argument and
basically what planning is says is
define a maximally great being to be a
being that is metaphysically necessary
omnipotent omniscient and morally
perfect now if it's possible that there
is such a being then there's a possible
world in which that being exists but if
a maximally great being exists in any
possible world it exists in all possible
worlds that's part of what it means to
be maximally great
therefore it exists in the actual world
therefore maximally great being exists
and the steps of this argument your
viewers may be surprised to learn are
actually relatively uncontroversial the
whole argument stands or Falls with the
first premise is it possible that a
maximally great being exists if you
think it's possible that God exists then
you ought to believe that God actually
exists the Atheist has to say not merely
that God does not exist but that it's
impossible that God exists
so the typical comeback doesn't even
meet this argument so just for the folks
who haven't studied the ontological
arguments at all the typical comeback is
imagine a maximally great Island the
greatest island you've ever heard of
well then it must exist by using the
exact same principles here but what you
would say is there's no there's no
possibility of a maximally great Island
because actually that description is
simply too vague there's no way to
actually that would be one of the
problems with it what contributes to the
greatness of violence do you prefer a
desert island or one chocked with hotel
resorts there isn't any really
objectively such a thing as the greatest
conceivable or maximally great island so
it turns out that these attempts to
parody the argument by talking about a
maximally great pizza or unnecessarily
existent Lion all fail because they
postulate incoherencies when the idea of
a maximally great being that is to say a
being that is omnipotent omniscient
early perfect in every possible world
does seem to be an intuitively coherent
and therefore possible idea so how do we
get from the idea of an unmoved mover in
in some of the arguments that you've
been making to the idea of a moral God
who cares about us and has involved in
the world
well it's quite right that arguments
like the cosmological argument or the
teleological or design argument which we
haven't talked about don't get you the
moral properties of the creator and
designer of the universe
but the moral argument and the auto
logical argument do both of those lead
to a being which is the moral paradigm
and source of all moral value and moral
obligation and so those arguments
complement the cosmological and
teleological arguments by telling us
something about the moral properties of
the creator and designer of the universe
now looking at those properties
what makes that being a god of mind
what makes that and what makes that
being constants meaning like present now
as opposed to the or the theistic
conception of a God who laid things in
motion may be embedded moral codes
within us and then walked away what
makes God something that that is present
in the universe at the moment on any
level okay now there's a couple of
questions there first with regard to why
I think this is a mind most all of the
arguments that I just shared do lead to
a personal intelligent creator that the
first argument does the teleological or
design argument leads to a cosmic
intelligence that has created the world
the moral argument leads to a personal
embodiment of moral value because
persons are the source of moral value
not inanimate things the auto logical
argument leads to a being who is
omniscient and morally perfect and
therefore is a person so these theistic
arguments don't just leave you with some
kind of unmoved mover they give you a
personal creator and designer of the
universe who is perfectly good now some
of them give you a being that is
metaphysically necessary
the second version of the cosmological
argument that I mentioned leads to a
being who exists by a necessity of his
own nature and therefore cannot fail to
exist the moral argument leads to a
being who is the paradigm and source of
all moral value now if you believe that
some moral values are necessary which
most ethicists do that means this being
is also necessary in his existence and
therefore having demonstrated that a
being like that exists it cannot fail to
be present in the world today that means
that this being also exists now it
couldn't cease to exist now that still
leaves open the question of deism has
this creator and designer of the
universe perfectly good revealed himself
to us in some way that we can know him
more personally or has he remained aloof
and distant from the world that he's
made that's still an open question to
talk about ok so let's talk about that
question yeah what meant the proofs that
you're talking about many of them can be
traced back to Aristotelian roots
Aquinas obviously talks about a lot of
these proofs himself but he's getting
them from Aristotle because they're also
present in in Maimonides that has the
same argument so with all of that said
that sort of brings us to the Tertullian
question which is ok so why do you need
Jerusalem so we've got we've got Athens
you've got you've got this idea of yes I
have a god that's presence in the
universe and that it has the moral
component to him there's the unmoved
mover all of these things so why do you
need the idea of revelatory God who
speaks to human beings the arguments
that we've discussed already narrowed
down the field of the world religions to
basically the great monotheistic faiths
Judaism Christianity and Islam or
perhaps deism the question as to which
of these is true I think stands or falls
upon the person of jesus of nazareth who
do you think Jesus of Nazareth was Jesus
claimed to be the decisive
self-revelation
of God and I believe that we have good
reasons to believe that those claims
were true
and that therefore the god revealed by
Jesus of Nazareth exists okay so let's
let's get into that so what are what is
the proof that Jesus was who he says he
is in the gospel well first we need to
establish who he thought he was when you
look at the religio historical context
of the life and Ministry of Jesus I
think you can show that among the
historically authentic words of Jesus
were claims that he thought he was the
Jewish Messiah that he believed himself
to be the Son of God in a unique sense
that set him apart from Jewish kings and
prophets and finally that he thought
that he was the son of man predicted by
the prophet Daniel to whom God would
give all Dominion power and authority so
he had this radical self understanding
of being Messiah son of God and the son
of man and at the trial scene before the
Sanhedrin in mark 15 all three of these
titles come to a head when the high
priest asks him are you the Messiah the
son of the Blessed One that is the son
of God and Jesus says I am and then
virtually quoting from Daniel and you
will see the Son of man coming on the
clouds of heaven and seated at the right
hand of the power and at that point the
high priest rips his robes and says you
have heard the blasphemy what more
witnesses do we need and mark says they
all condemned him as worthy of death and
that enabled them since they didn't have
the ability to carry out capital
punishment to deliver him over to the
Roman authorities by slandering him as a
pretender to be king of the Jews and
therefore a political figure who could
be tried for treason and Sedition and
crucified so from the Jewish perspective
the this this narrative has some holes
in sort of Jewish philosophy the the
narrative begin
with the idea that Jesus appears in
front of the Sanhedrin and then claims
to be the Messiah well there's nothing
actual criminally in in any of the
tractates that say that if you declare
yourself the Messiah this is actually a
punishment a punishable offense you know
they're there many Jews including Bar
Kochba who have declared themselves
messianic figures the real gap here is
that in the Gospels Jesus's vision of
himself as the Messiah is completely
different from the prior vision of what
the Jewish Messiah is and is actually
outside the scope of how Jews described
the Messiah or really have ever
described the Messiah the Messiah and
Judaism has always been a political
figure who is destined to do certain
things restoring the Kingdom of Israel
we maintaining control of that Kingdom
bringing more Jews back to Israel all of
these things are considered sort of
political things that the Messiah does
but the idea of the Messiah as
embodiment of God is something that's
foreign to Jewish religious philosophy
going all the way back to the beginning
so even the idea that the Sanhedrin
would be questioning him in those terms
and would get from that that what he
means is I am God which would be a much
more punishable offense presume without
the actual blasphemy that that's it's
it's an oddity I think you're absolutely
right in saying that Jesus understanding
of the Messiah was radically different
from the prevailing cultural
understanding of the Messiah among the
chief priests and the common people and
he didn't meet their expectations indeed
that's what helped to get him crucified
being the Messiah you're right in and of
itself isn't a blasphemous claim but to
claim to be the Son of God in a unique
sense and then especially the son of man
prophesied by Daniel sitting at the
right hand of the power that is truly
blasphemous and is sufficient for his
condemnation now the question I think
that is raised by your interesting yes
yeah your interpretation been is this
why should we believe Jesus
reinterpretation of the Messiah rather
than the one that the chief priests and
the people held and I think the answer
to that is his resurrection from the
dead Jesus resurrection from the dead is
Yahweh's public and unequivocal
vindication of the man whom the chief
priests had rejected as a blasphemer it
is the divine demonstration that these
allegedly blasphemous claims are in fact
true that he was who he claimed to be
and that therefore I follow Jesus in his
conception of what it means to be the
Messiah so when it comes to the
resurrection why is resurrection proof
of divinity so Lazarus is is reservoir
that was why I wanted to emphasize the
religio historical context before we
talked about the resurrection a miracle
taken in isolation is inherently
ambiguous the proper interpretation of a
miracle is going to be given by the
religio historical context in which it
occurs and the resurrection of Jesus is
not just the resurrection of any old
body it's the resurrection of the man
who claimed to be Messiah son of God and
Son of Man and who was crucified for
those allegedly blasphemous claims if
God has raised this man from the dead
then he has I think unequivocally and
publicly vindicated those allegedly
blasphemous claims so one of the
counterclaims to some of this is that
the Gospels are written significantly
after Jesus lives even the earliest
gospel is written what 7dc someone
somewhere somewhere 40 years after after
Jesus is crucified so what's to say I
mean that like most historical events
there is some play in the joints here so
that this would be the historical
argument against the exact veracity of
the gospel revelations well now I think
it's important to understand Ben that in
order for a historical document to be
reliable it isn't required that it be
in an attempt radius of course solace
what I would argue is that underlying
the inference to the resurrection of
Jesus are three great independently
established facts which are supported by
the historical evidence and which
surprisingly I did my doctoral work on
this in Germany are recognized as such
by the majority of New Testament
scholars today who studied the
historical Jesus and these facts would
be that after his crucifixion and burial
by a member of the Sanhedrin named
Joseph of Arimathea the Jesus tomb was
discovered empty on the first day of the
week by a group of his female followers
secondly would be that various
individuals and groups of people then
witnessed appearances of Jesus alive and
finally number three would be that the
original disciple suddenly and sincerely
came to believe that God had raised
Jesus from the dead despite having every
predisposition to the contrary the vast
majority of scholars have come to accept
as convincing the evidence in support of
those three facts not assuming biblical
inerrancy or inspiration but treating
the Gospels as ordinary historical
documents you can show for example that
the fact of the discovery of the empty
tomb is attested by at least six
independent sources in the New Testament
some of which are extraordinaire aliy
early no scholar denies that individuals
and groups saw post-mortem appearances
of Jesus the only question is whether
you should or could dismiss them as
hallucinatory and again nobody denies
that the original disciples suddenly and
sincerely came to believe that God had
raised Jesus from the dead so these
three facts are pretty firmly
established and the only question is
then how do you best explain them and
down through history attempts
made to explain these facts without
recourse to the resurrection like the
conspiracy theory the apparent death
Theory the hallucination theory and so
forth and I would argue that none of
these naturalistic theories meets the
criteria for being the best historical
explanation of the facts none of them is
as good an explanation as the one that
the original disciples gave that God
raised Jesus from the dead and if that's
right then I think we have good grounds
indeed are almost compelled to revise
our typical understanding of who the
Messiah was supposed to be so we can
have the historical argument back and
forth obviously and I think that their
arguments that you can make I think the
arguments that I can make back obviously
find them relatively uninteresting is
the truth simply because I'm not sure
that we're going to come to any sort of
consensus on them you know on the on the
historical argument for example I think
it's fairly easy to claim there's
there's a sect of Judaism right now in
which there's a sub small subsection of
people who believe that the lubavitcher
rebbe is still alive randal above ature
Rebbe passed away in the 1990s and
there's still people who treat him as
though he is not dead
they call him the Messiah they think
they're obviously political Messiah they
have and and they still do that twenty
years after his death you know that's
not proof to me that he is actually
alive some of the more experienced it
right so you know especially when you're
talking about events 2,000 years ago if
people write that down I think there's
this man's tomb is empty I mean I
haven't dug him up so I would know but
the the claims if somebody claims 2,000
years from now that his tomb was empty
or claimed seven years from now that his
tomb was empty then yeah that's an
important difference Ben the important
time gap is not the gap between the
events and the present good evidence
doesn't become bad evidence just because
of the lapse of time the critical event
as you just said is the time gap between
the events and the recording of those
correct events and in the case of the
events of the life of Jesus and his
resurrection that time gap is
extraordinarily narrow we can push back
even before the writing of the Gospels
and the epistles of Paul by discerning
the traditions upon which they relied
when they wrote and some of these go
back to within it's estimated five years
after Jesus crucifixion I'm thinking of
the ones that Paul transmits in to the
Corinthian church in 1st Corinthians 15
so we're on pretty good ground there in
terms of the earliness and the
multiplicity of our sources for the life
of Jesus so let's talk for a second
about sort of the necessity for
judeo-christian revelation because and
here I'm gonna merge the two in terms of
the idea of God personally speaking to
people and giving them the morality of
the Old Testament and which largely is
reflected in the New Testament and the
New Testament is part of the Old
Testament according to Christians anyway
it reflects the the chief morality of
the Old Testament it doesn't supplant it
entirely the Old Testament doesn't
become nothing just because the New
Testament comes around so that's why I'm
now moving back toward the kind of
theological question which is what's the
purpose of the revelation meaning could
we would it be sufficient to work within
the framework of the first half of our
conversation with regard to sort of
rational pushes not toward revelation
and the presence of God in human form
and Christianity or the presence of God
on top of mountain and Judaism what a
God of reason alone be sufficient or do
you need to have for what purpose do you
need to have a God who is speaking
directly to people at Sinai or speaking
through Jesus in Christianity I think
that the answer of both the Hebrew Bible
and the New Testament can be put into
one word atonement what is needed is
atonement for sin and in the Levitical
sacrifices in the tabernacle and later
in the temple you had a sacrificial
system whereby atonement was made for
sin through the sacrifice of various
animals and
Jesus himself and the authors of the New
Testament think of Jesus as being the
ultimate sacrificial offering to God to
make atonement once and for all for the
sins of mankind so that in his
sacrificial death on the cross he
fulfills all of these Jewish antecedents
or foreshadowing of a decisive atonement
for sin that will reconcile us to God
and bring forgiveness and pardon and
cleansing
so you've debated a bevy of atheists and
agnostics on a variety of topics which
was the debate that you felt was most
challenging for you I think the best
debate that I've ever had was with a
professor of philosophy at North
Carolina State University named Doug
Joseph the back story behind this debate
is that even though I would be on the
affirmative and therefore normally go
first he insisted on going first in the
debate and I thought something is
suspicious here he wants to launch a
preemptive attack on my argument so that
before I even get up I'm already behind
the eight ball and so I insisted that I
go first in the debate and we had to
decide it by a coin flip of the
departmental secretary and he won and so
got to go first and so sure enough he
got up there and in his opening speech
he launched into a withering attack on
every one of my five arguments for God's
existence before I even got up to speak
and I thought oh man how am I gonna get
out from behind this well I had prepared
a short speech from my opening so that
it would leave me about five minutes of
time extemporaneously to respond to his
pre-emptive attack and Trunks tried to
level the playing field again and so
that was what I did and then the debate
just went back and forth back and forth
right down to the final rebuttals it was
a great
debate and afterwards I went up to him
and I said you are a very good debater
and he said Thanks
I was on my university debate team and I
thought oh man so here's a guy who had
both the philosophical training and the
debate training that I have and as a
result it was a great contest a really
good debate and one of those
conversations have you ever found
yourself doubting your own principles
have you ever found yourself thinking
that maybe the other person might be
right or shifting on your core instantly
doubting though I think there have been
a couple of times rather rare where the
other fellows thrown a curveball at me
that I wasn't expecting I prep hard for
these debates and prepare briefs like a
lawyer would for anticipated objections
but in my debate for example my first
debate at Purdue University with Austin
Dacey of the American Humanist
he threw a couple of arguments out there
that I hadn't thought about before and
so I had to kind of wing it and that was
difficult and after the debate I was
rather dissatisfied with my performance
and I thought if if I ever get a chance
I want to debate Dacey again and sure
enough a couple years later I got an
invitation to have a debate at Fresno
State University with Austin Dacey and
this time I was prepared to the held and
so it went much better so there been
times when there have been curveball so
to speak but for the most part honestly
been for the most part these fellows
don't prepare they're so arrogant
they're so sure of themselves that they
think they're just gonna blow away this
Bible pounding ignoramus and that if
they just trot out their arguments from
philosophy 101 that everything will go
well and they usually are pretty
surprised so let's talk about a couple
of those philosophy arguments from 101
that are constantly trotted out I've had
similar experiences the most common one
that I've heard of course is the problem
of evil the suggestion that how can God
be good if so much evil takes place in
the world the more sophisticated version
of the argument to me is not the problem
of human evil which seems pretty easily
disposable but the
the problem of natural evil things
happening to children a child with
cancer how does a good God
rule over a world in which children die
of natural causes in which kids are born
with tay-sachs
in which horrible things happen to good
people yes in dealing with this problem
I think it's really important that we
distinguish between what I call the
intellectual problem of evil and the
emotional problem of evil there is no
doubt that emotionally the evil and
suffering in the world make it very
difficult to believe in God it's a
tremendous emotional obstacle but
intellectually considered
dispassionately as a philosophical
problem it's extraordinarily difficult
to show that there's either any
inconsistency or improbability between
the existence of an all-loving
all-powerful God and the evil and
suffering in the world the Atheist would
have to show that it is either
impossible or improbable that God has
morally sufficient reasons for
permitting the natural and moral evil in
the world and how could he possibly show
that we're simply not in a position to
make those kind of probability judgments
with any confidence and so I think that
the problem of evil as difficult as it
may be emotionally intellectually it
lays a burden of proof on the shoulders
of the atheist which is so heavy that it
has proved to be unsustainable and these
days the the other argument that is
brought up an enormous amount is the
supposed backwardness of the Bible
itself and biblical morality this
happens largely with regard to for
example a homosexual marriage it's been
brought up with regard to abortion which
i think is more again easily disposable
to them there's a solid second or
argument in favor of protection of human
life but homosexual marriage is the one
that most often comes up you also hear
arguments that the Bible permits slavery
so if the Bible is so wonderful then why
are there all these weird sections of
the Bible where it talks about wiping
peoples from the earth where it talks
about where it talks about enslaving
other human beings some things that we
would certainly consider more
evils today are contemplated by the
Bible and not banned by the Bible so why
why is that well let me address briefly
first this question of slavery when we
hear the word slavery Bend we think of
slavery as it existed in the American
South and as you know that is nothing
like the system that existed in ancient
Israel in ancient Israel there was no
social safety net sponsored by the state
there was no poverty program so if a man
got himself into a situation where he
couldn't pay his debts
he could keep his family together and
retain his self-respect
by selling himself as an indentured
servant to his creditor until he could
work off his debts and then he would
have to be set free after seven years he
had to be set free in any case so this
was really a form of indentured servant
hood it wasn't slavery as we think of
that term this was actually an
anti-poverty program and in some
respects I think it's better than what
we have in modern Western culture which
destroys families ruins people's
self-respect because they're not working
whereas in ancient Israel a man retained
his self-respect he worked for an income
he paid his debts he kept his family
together and that to call that slavery
is just a gross misrepresentation now
the first thing you mentioned I've
forgotten a sexual marriage yes
entertainers with respect to some of
these other moral questions I think we
need to remember the first premise of
the moral argument if there is no God
then there are no objective moral values
and duties
everything is socio-culturally relative
so who's to say that the moral values of
a society that discriminates against
people and oppresses people is worse
than one which is liberal and tolerant
we just sort of assumed that the
the liberal values are the ones that
would be objective when in fact they're
just as relativistic as any of the other
ones on atheism so if we need God to be
the anchor point for objective moral
values and duties we cannot escape the
question when thinking of moral right
and wrong well what does God think of
this and if god prescribes something it
seems to me that's entirely within his
right if God were to say thou shalt not
eat beans or thou shalt not eat pork
that would be our moral duty and we
should obey it that is his prerogative
as the moral lawgiver and the supreme
good and so if God says my plan for
human sexuality is heterosexual marriage
that's his prerogative and there is no
basis for calling that I think into
question so let's talk about the
evolution of morality and I want to go
back to slavery for just a second so it
is true that that Hebrew enslavement the
Jewish enslavement of others is really
more indentured servitude and there's a
whole section in I believe it's it's
numbers or Leviticus insula Medicus
maybe where it speaks just specifically
about the slave who doesn't want to
leave and you're supposed to Pierce is
here on the doorpost as a punishment for
him not wanting to leave an officer but
by the same token opus enslavement of
people who are not inside the the
Israelite inside the Jewish kind of
tradition that's not proscribed so the
idea of war captives is obviously taken
into account and not banned so certain
things are banned the Bible certain
things are not banned now the way that
biblical believers have practiced over
time is that very early in the church's
history they're already starting to
eliminate slavery although not for
people who are captured and then over
time the West is the first place to
eliminate slavery altogether
specifically citing the sections of the
Bible to talk about human freedom and
the innate value of every human being so
is that an evolution of morality or is
that a realization of a fundamental
principle that was originally given to
people who couldn't necessarily
understand the full extent of the
principle I think I think it's the
latter and I
love the way you put it I think that's
nicely put Jesus said something very
much like this with respect to Old
Testament regulations on divorce they
asked him whether or not it was lawful
to divorce a woman for any reason and
Jesus said Moses allowed you to write a
certificate of divorce but it was not so
from the beginning and he cites then the
creation story of Genesis of Adam and
Eve and said what God has put together
in lot let not man put asunder
so what Jesus was saying there was that
the law of Moses was a temporary
prescription accommodating the hardness
of heart of the people at the time but
it didn't represent the perfect will of
God for human marriage which was
grounded in the creation story so how
exactly do we determine when we have
moved beyond the biblical text in terms
of the evolution of that morality when
are we fulfilling a broader goal that
was that you know was kind of held back
by temporary constraints and when are we
moving
utterly beyond it and again here I'm
thinking of same-sex marriage so when it
comes to same-sex marriage the argument
is now being made by people in liberal
churches including including Peabody
Judge who's running for president that
basically Jesus was seeking equal
respect for everyone he cared about the
least of these and the prescriptions on
homosexuality were really more an
homosexual activity were not eternal
precepts but we're really attempting to
crack down on the promiscuity of the
time or they were temporary expedience
yeah I think that's clearly false when
you look at these regulations both in
the Old Testament and then they're
repeated in the New Testament in the
strongest terms in Romans chapter 1
there's no doubt that Paul is thinking
of this as a moral law that has abiding
significance and it's grounded again I
think in the creation story that God has
created human sexualities created
woman in such a way that the fulfillment
of that relationship will take place
within the safety and security of a
heterosexual marriage and that outside
of that sexual activity is not to be
indulged in and this is a law that God
has given us for our good so I do not
think that this is capable of simply
being relativized to time and culture so
when you argue with students when you
talk with students and discuss with them
what do you find is the best way to
approach them when it comes to the
precepts of traditional judeo-christian
morality do you come at it from the
natural law perspective or do you come
at it from the biblical perspective I
guess I share with them the moral
argument that I shared earlier in our
interview this moral argument is very
powerful with students because on the
one hand they've been taught relativism
they are scared to death of imposing
their values on someone else so it seems
right to them that if God does not exist
that objective moral values don't exist
they think their subjective person
dependent and relative but then secondly
the premise also seems true to them that
objective moral values do exist they
think it's objectively wrong to impose
your moral values on someone else and
the values of tolerance open-mindedness
and love have been deeply ingrained to
them and so they believe both of the
premises but have just never connected
the dots to see what logically follows
from it and this can lead to some
bizarre conversations I remember with
one fellow when we would talk about
premise 1 he would agree with it and
deny - so when we talk about premise 2
he'd agree with that and then deny one
and so we went back and forth back and
forth with this poor fellow flailing to
try to escape the logical conclusions of
what he himself believed so I find
approaching it through this moral
argument as the best way one of the
things that's been fascinating to watch
is people broadly accepting
the efficacy of the precepts of religion
without accepting the underlying truth
of religion so here I would point to my
friend Jordan Peterson who talks a lot
about the practices of basically what
our religious practices the idea make
your room do the moral thing duty but he
doesn't talk in specifically religious
terms he speaks in union terms he talks
about the idea of deeper precepts that
are embedded in myth which is really
embedded in the human psyche he doesn't
make the the kind of truth of religion
argument he instead makes the if you
want to get ahead you're gonna have to
do this stuff argument for wanna be
happy you're gonna have to do this stuff
argument and that has tremendous
cultural appeal do you think that that
is beneficial do you think that that is
enough where how far do you think that
goes I think it's beneficial but it's
not enough when I had a dialogue in
Toronto last year with Jordan Peterson
rather than attack his position what I
tried to do is to be Invitational and
say look you and I both affirm the
objectivity of moral values and meaning
in life I want to offer you something I
want to offer you a grounding for those
values that we both hold dear because
for him as you say been there just sort
of floating in the air they don't have
any metaphysical ground in his worldview
so he's got the right values and and and
meaning by and large but he has no basis
for them and I'm still hopeful that he
will come to embrace God has an
objective metaphysical reality who will
provide a basis for those values and
meaning in life I mean one of the things
that I've found really fascinating is as
I say so many people are embracing
fundamental principles of religion and
even the sort of quasi pantheistic idea
but the the religious idea nonetheless
that there is a moving force behind the
universe where implicit in the universe
and yet the minute you say God people
tend to run for the hills because they
immediately identify their boring Sunday
School class so how exactly do we bridge
that gap for folks who may have been
alienated from religion by a sort of
simplistic view of religion that they
got growing up how do how do you react
eight people in the precepts of religion
well as you probably noticed in talking
with me back
I don't lead with the Bible I lead with
philosophical arguments beginning very
generally there's a creator of the
cosmos there's a designer of the
universe there is an absolute moral good
which furnishes a basis for moral values
and duties and then I began to ask well
who is Jesus of Nazareth what did he
claim why should we believe what he said
and then finally and ultimately I'll try
to make the personal application and say
what difference could this make in your
life and sometimes I'll share then my
story personally of how I raised in a an
unbelieving family came to believe in
Christ at the age of 16 and had my life
completely upended and turned around and
so by beginning philosophically I think
you can lead into then a more religious
and personal faith the people will feel
comfortable with well maybe you could
share that story so what what made you
religious I'm religious since birth I
grew up in a Jewish home we were we were
fairly religious from the time that I
was young we became fully Orthodox when
I was 11 but it was with my parents the
hope you know my whole entire immediate
family but how did you become a
religious person I don't think of myself
as religious but I understand that
you're using the word in the wrong
people so yeah in high school I was
going through a deep existential crisis
looking for meaning in life the meaning
of my existence who I was I later
discovered existentialist philosophers
were asking the same questions and I
never knew it so I was filled with
darkness and despair as I saw my
impending death the impending death of
the universe and no meaning to it all
and I walked into my high-school German
class one day and I sat down behind a
girl who's one of these types you know
that is always so happy it just makes
you a sec and I tapped her on the
shoulder and she turned around and I I
said to her Sandi what are you always so
happy
about anyway and she said it's because I
know Jesus Christ is my personal Savior
and I said you what III said well I've
gone to church and she said well that's
not enough bill you've got to have him
really living in your heart and I said
well what would a to a thing like that
for
and she said because he loves you bill
and that just hit me like a ton of
bricks here I was so filled with despair
and and anger and she said there was
someone who really loved me and who was
it but the God of the universe and that
thought just staggered me
to think that the God of the universe
could love me
bill Craig that worm down there on that
speck of dust called planet Earth I just
couldn't take it in well I went home
that night and found a New Testament and
for the first time in my life I opened
it and began to read it and as I did I
was absolutely captivated by the person
of Jesus of Nazareth
there was a wisdom about this man's
teachings that I had never encountered
before and there was an authenticity
about his life that I couldn't deny and
as I read the New Testament I saw why
God seemed so unreal to me it was
because my sin my moral wrongdoing it
created a separation between me and God
so that I was alienated from him and
couldn't experience that love
relationship that he had created me to
have but that he had sent Christ to
atone for those sins and that through
Christ I could have forgiveness and a
restoration of that relationship and so
after about six months of the most
intense soul-searching that I've ever
been through one night I just came to
the end of my rope and cried out to God
and I felt this tremendous infusion of
joy like a balloon being blown up and
blown up until it was ready to burst and
I rushed outside it was a warm
Midwestern September evening and as I
looked up at the sky I could see the
Milky Way from Horizon to Horizon as I
looked up this
stars I thought God I've come to know
God and that moment changed my whole
life
because I had thought enough about this
during those six months to realize that
if Bill Craig ever became a Christian I
could do nothing less than give my
entire life to spreading this message
among mankind because if this is really
the truth if it's really the truth it's
the greatest news ever announced and so
my call to Christian ministry was
simultaneous with my conversion
experience and I've never looked back so
in just a second I don't ask you one
final question which is in a world where
it seems like religion as you say seems
to be waning more broadly even if it's
being held more dearly by by a smaller
number do you see people filling the the
void with sort of air SATs meaning and
where do you see that the gravest
threats to civilization coming from I'm
gonna ask you that question in just one
sacrament if you want to hear dr.
William Lane Craig zan sir you actually
have to subscribe over here it's daily
wire to subscribe go to daily wire calm
click Subscribe you can hear the end of
our conversation over there dr. Craig
thank you much so much for stopping by I
really appreciate your time
I really appreciate your work and if you
go check out more of dr. Craig's work at
reasonable faith org I think you're
gonna find a lot there that is edifying
thanks so much for stopping thank you
Ben I've really enjoyed our conversation
[Music]
Avenger Pierrot shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis clever edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and hula the
Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]